jegliche in diesem video verwendete
wortwahl beleidigungen vorwürfe gegen
die person beim hd sind lediglich zweck
des humors benutzt worden und sollen
spaß bzw satire verstanden werden
hh die neue station kontakt operation ja
erst mal schön dass die zeit gefunden
haben hier mit uns über diesen gewissen
g-punkt hd zu reden dass hier sein darf
ok schön zunächst erst mal eine ganz
kleine frage und zwar wer ist denn
überhaupt dieser ominöse gibt adeya
dieser ominöse geb und hd oder volksmund
auch kubä genannt ist die er sich nennen
ein unterhalter und er legt auf der
social media plattform youtube
regelmäßig gaming content unternehmen
damit ja sage und schreibe mehr als
800.000 menschen und wann bemerkten sie
dass mit herrn hd etwas nicht stimmt
wenn sie das schon seit monaten klagen
verliert dieser mensch ist zwar harmlos
an als 100 menschen mehr projekten
getötet und seine bude ausgeübt hatte
obwohl diese durch die regelsetzung
vollkommen verboten überhaupt nicht
übertrieben gibt immer den command für
das tnt jedoch verbindungen zwischen
g-punkt hd und die illuminaten
hergestellten erwiesen wurden wurde ich
immer misstrauischer doch die jetzige
aktion brachte dann halt quasi das fass
zum überlaufen sein ok und die wir uns
dieser aktion beschreiben es war quasi
als akt der verzweiflung nachdem herr hd
in dem online zb quaid nichts und wieder
nichts auf die
vor den ferien wütend auch nicht wie ist
dann halt leider hat die heraus ich bin
gestorben
nein das ganze dann aus zu beginn spielt
er mit aktionen gegen mich auf der us
ölplattform twitter welche er dann
allerdings in die realität umsetzt
einige tage später wurde mir von
mehreren quellen ein video zugetragen
welchen mein gesicht auf ingame
basierten kreaturen auftauchte
hochgeladen auf den illuminaten kanal hd
wie gehen sie damit dann um ich als
erwachsener mann hat mich das natürlich
überhaupt nicht beeindrucken lassen und
gehen sofort liegt an einer sprache sind
uns wäre diese rache wie sie diese sache
denn bei ihnen dann außen ja eine ganz
kurze sache noch eigeninteresse und zwar
im sie eigentlich hier an irgendwie rom
gedacht oder so jetzt an herrn hd ja
klar eigentlich so an jedem zeitpunkt
mehr oder weniger scheidet er soll nicht
mehr an
also hätten
das video war natürlich nur ein spaß an
alle die es wollen euch verstanden haben
nach dem display man anfangen doch jetzt
dem trollbeads ich habe mir einfach
gedacht nach dem gemisch in seine texte
gepackt hat macht doch auch mal so eine
kleine aktion es sollte eigentlich so
werden dass sich das ganze texture pack
dass ich mir ein ganzes spektrum nehmer
und alles durch gomez gesicht ersetze
aber irgendwie waren wir das zu viel
arbeit habe ich mir gedacht ob ich mal
die fresse von den testern auf und kopf
der
ich will auf jeden fall sagen wenn es
euch gefallen hat würde ich mich
definitiv über bilden wird dieses heft
würde ich mich definitiv bei der
bewertung freuen weil ich da jetzt
glaube ich drei stunden dann saß ich
komme jetzt zu spät zu unserem termin wo
wir jetzt ins neue jahr feiern
aber ich wünsche euch auf jeden fall ein
frohes neues jahr oder einen guten
rutsch jetzt wenn ihr das video jetzt
bitte nicht zu ernst nehmen dieses video
und wir sehen uns dann im nächsten jahr
wieder andere machen soll jahres sollte
wirklich mal sonnenschein